ich wünsche dir ganz viel glück
weiterhin und auch schöne grüße
natürlich an meine kinder von mir man
muss ja immer so ein bisschen vorsorgen
ich meine stelle sich vor in fünf jahren
auf youtube sind die kinder angenommen
acht und neun jahre alt lieblings
youtuber steht dann schon lange fest
alex beh etwas glaubt netz bekommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut ich komme
gerade frisch aus paris wieder war ich
vorher noch nie war wirklich eine gute
stadt kann man auf jeden fall mal hin
darum geht es heute aber natürlich gar
nicht vor ungefähr einer woche kam der
zweite part von ungeschminkte weiß
geschminkt das heißt er hat mir wieder
sehr viele fotos von mach ich auch wenns
darum zugeschickt und darunter war ein
top kommentar ich könnte mir einfach mal
kurz einblenden übrigens weiß ich heute
besonders schreibe meine ohren sitzt ein
bisschen zu das merke ich gar nicht
irgendjemand hat geschrieben
irgendwie so von wegen erwartet doch mal
das alter dazu ich habe heute keine back
tim rauszusuchen deswegen gebe ich das
jetzt einfach so wieder und ich habe mir
gedacht eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlechte idee
ich meine das alter erraten habe ich
zwar schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht ich
war glaube ich sogar fast der erste das
gemacht hat da war und deswegen würde
ich sagen wir machen das hat einfach mal
ich hoffe park boot ist rausgesucht die
schau mal das jetzt zusammen an beraten
bisschen was alter vergleichen das und
wie immer schon gesagt das ganze soll
natürlich nicht oberflächlich überkommen
schminken ist etwas ganz natürliches
machen sehr viele die einen sehen damit
älter aus die anderen jünger die anderen
besser die anderen schlechter gehört
natürlich auch noch was subjektives dazu
wir schauen einfach mal rein
ich würde sagen können das ist jetzt
schon mal in fetten noch nach oben let's
go und zwar fangen wir an mit der ersten
person
hier haben wir die mit namen habe ich es
nicht so ich habe den haben schon wieder
vergessen auf jeden fall würde ich euch
direkt man auf das andere foto ein weil
ich mal wieder keinen plan hat welches
jetzt ja ungeschminkt ist und welches
geschminkt hier bei dem schwarz-weißen
sieht man so ein bisschen da sind die
augen gemacht wir gehen einfach mal
davon aus wobei ich hier finde sie sieht
ungeschminkt älter aus als geschminkt
würde ich halt summe auf keine ahnung 16
oder 17 schätzen also ich finde da ist
gar nicht so ein großer unterschied
zwischen und wir haben sieht saukomisch
aus egal
bis 20 sorry dass ich dich jetzt noch
jung geschätzt habe ich hoffe da ist es
mir nicht übel nimmt es einfach als
kompliment und wir machen weiter
er ist übrigens hanna also schöne grüße
an hanna mit dieser person
das ist das geschmückte kann man auch
ganz klar sehen weil sie das am
schminktisch gemacht hat schwierig
schwierig wir schauen uns einfach mal
das ungeschminkte dazu an sind nämlich
bei der schwingt zumindest wenn das
jetzt das ungeschminkte sein soll ist
das ja ein bisschen bearbeitet sich
jetzt irgendwie auch sagen so wirklich
einen unterschied erkenne ich da nicht
die person würde ich allerdings
vielleicht schon so 18 schätzen sieht
vielleicht geschminkt noch ein kleines
bisschen älter aus aber da beide bilder
glaube ich auch da ein bisschen
bearbeitet sind kann man da nicht mehr
so wirklich was erkennen
sie ist 19 also ein jahr älter gar nicht
mal so schlecht so gut wir brauchen
jetzt wirklich mal etwas schwierigeres
deswegen hoffen wir mal auf den nächsten
fall
hier haben wir die warte mal habe ich ja
einmal kim in ungeschminkt vision ich
habe jetzt einfach mal so vor ich würde
sagen hier so 16 gut sagen wir 17 17
jahre und hier ja gut das ist und hier
könnte man dann sagen ich sage einfach
mal weil ich jetzt einmal drunter war
neunzehn ich wollte 18 sagen wir sagen
und sie also die kirmes 19 habe ich
anscheinend gut erraten ich denke mir
nur gerade irgendwie wo sind die ganzen
jungen zuschauer bei normalerweise wenn
ich solche folgen drehen sind die
meisten halt 14 15 16 viele schick mir
auch was zu die älter sind aber die
meisten sind halt länger und wir hatten
jetzt nur 18 19 und 20 jährige oder so
aber freut mich natürlich
wir machen weiter auch an dicht im
schöne grüße wir haben hier die cat
einmal ein ungeschminkt glaube ich und
das war ungeschlagen sie für mich
irgendwie auch direkt schon wieder älter
aus würde ich jetzt so höre hier nur das
ungeschminkt sieht dieses sehr sehr
schwierig sie können 14 sein können aber
auch schon so 20 sein wisst ihr dass ich
meinen aber hier sieht man ja wirklich
dass sie sich schon gut schwingen kann
wobei das eigentlich auch mit 14
heutzutage schon möglich ist schwierig
also beschränkt auf jeden fall auf ihre
18 ungeschminkt sag ich mal unter 18 und
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal 21
das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht mal so
gedacht ich hätte eher 18 gesagt ich
frage mich gerade wieder wieso sind alle
so als sonst immer alle 14 15 16 17 und
heutigen video 20 27
jetzt kommt bestimmt waren der jüngere
ist und ich schaue mal kurz hier haben
wir die karten und hna.de punkt 05 du
bist schon wirklich 13
das ist 05 verrät jetzt mehr als sollte
einmal hierhin ungeschminkt ja
ungeschminkt wobei ich ja auch irgendwie
sagen muss wenn man sich jetzt das
ungeschminkte anschaut nochmal hier wie
sie viel älter aus als geschminkt ihr
könntet ihr wirklich noch als zehn
durchgehend vielleicht elf mut
vielleicht macht das auch die brille
jetzt hier
man weiß es nicht und sie ist halt
vermutlich 13 ich bin zwölf aber bald
bin ich 13
wenn du 2005 geboren bist kannst du
nicht zwölf säulen 2006 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18
doch wenn sie jetzt erst im oktober
november oder dezember geburtstag hatte
sorry jetzt komme ich mir noch etwas
luft vor aber wohl tot
wir machen weiter und zwar hat mir auch
einen junge bilder zugeschickt glaube
ich genau und zwar immer das bild
ungeschminkt ja ist ja ganz klar so ich
hab mir auch mal kurz ein profil
angeschaut und er schmeckt sicherheit
gerne ist ja auch überhaupt nichts dran
für dich mega cool dass du mir ja die
bilder zugeschickt hast wenn man das
jetzt so sieht würde ich schon so sagen
bestimmt 22 wenn man dann das geht würde
ich eigentlich auch noch sagen
mindestens 22 und wir schauen einfach
mal rein
und 19 ich hatte jetzt werde ich im
älter geschätzt schöne grüße an farbe
kann man sich auf jeden fall glaube ich
das profil anschauen ist relativ
interessant von nicht also wenn ihr bock
drauf habt ich hoffe das ist okay schaut
gern mal vorbei du weißt die einzige
junge bis jetzt in allen drei folgen
es ist ja auch mutig so was hier zu
schicken deswegen danke auf jeden fall
wir machen weiter die nächste person
carina ist anscheinend unterwegs auf
tickt ob das hier ist die glaube ich
einmal umgestimmt genau und das
geschminkt und geschenk für dich sagen
mindestens 17 18 jahre alt ich sagen
einfach mal 18 jahre alt war ja
irgendwie alle gerade irgendwie älter
sind als ich denke dass geschminkte
könnte er auch schon 20 21 sein
vielleicht auch ich sage einfach mal 20
also geschminkt sie sieht noch mal älter
aus als ungeschminkt und sie ist 23
jahre seit dem 18 19 und zweifache
mutter muss scheinen ungeschminkt weist
es nicht geschminkt videos check
lebensziel erreicht nicht auch cool dass
du mir fotos zugeschickt hat ich wünsche
dir ganz viel glück weiterhin und auch
schöne grüße natürlich an meine kinder
von mir man muss ja immer so ein
bisschen vorsorgen ich meine stellt euch
vor fünf jahren habe ich auf youtube
sind die kinder angenommen acht und neun
jahre alt lieblings youtuber steht schon
lange fest alex fiva sie war glaube ich
die patrizia immerhin ungeschminkt
trinkt allerdings von alkohol deswegen
mindestens 16 jahre alt würde ich jetzt
hier einfach mal sagen 16 in geschminkt
sieht noch älter ausfindig ich glaube
dann sind wir schon bei 19 und sie ist
wäre dann nur dann mal 21 er glaubte ich
verstehe wirklich nicht wieso so viele
vergleichsweise ältere personen heute
dabei sind ich meine wie schon gesagt
freut mich aber normalerweise sind die
älteren eher so die spielerinnen und
schickten wir gar nichts ich weiß zwar
dass auch ältere zuschauen weil man
manchmal auf der straße mitten in der
nacht um 3 uhr im club von älteren
leuten auch angesprochen hier aber wie
gesagt sind eher so die schülerin
ungeschminkt weiß geschminkt selber
abend erst geschwenkt drei stunden
später dann abgeschminkt werde übrigens
im november 21 und werden geschminkt
immer nach ausweis gefragt ich habe mir
sogar gesagt 16
ab und an sogar bei dingen ab 16
schreibt auch gern jetzt mal die
kommentare wie alt seid ihr und werdet
ihr nach dem ausweis gefragt vielleicht
seid ihr auf 14 sieht aber aus wie 25
leute ich würde sagen wir hatten jetzt
wieder einige personen dabei danke dass
ihr mir immer diese ganzen fotos schickt
das geht wirklich heftig ab deswegen
wenn du auch dabei sein willst schaut
gern auf instagram vorbei schickt mir da
dein foto lasst uns hatten nach oben da
wenn ich das noch mal machen soll und
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder ein neues cooles video bis dahin
haut rein
tja und ganz wichtig abonnieren nicht
vergessen